we're learning more about the future of
the district represented by the late
congressman john lewis he served atlanta
and surrounding areas for more than 33
years
now georgia democrats have selected
nakima williams currently a state
senator
to run to replace him in november
meanwhile the tributes and memories are
pouring in cbs
cbs this morning saturday co-host
michelle miller is in atlanta where she
spoke to friends who knew lewis well
a stream of admirers of all races and
backgrounds unified here in the shadow
of the late john lewis
those who knew him best say it's his
humanity and compassion that set him
apart
activist ernona clayton was a
decades-long friend of both lewis and
his wife of almost
45 years lillian oh i've put them
together
you said lillian and john up yeah oh
yeah
married them all just married them all
over lillian's objection
and then i said to john just for recent
years i said john you know come to think
i don't think you ever said yes or no he
said you didn't give me a chance
rosa tyner is john lewis's sister the
youngest of 10 children
i was very small when i used to see him
on tv
at first i wondered why he was getting
arrested
from his birth onto his death
he was still standing up for what's
right congressman lewis is the reason
that i ran for office councilman khalid
kamal
represents atlanta's twin city south
fulton
when you see a scene like this what
comes to your mind
that this man just had an effect on
generations
of people particularly black folks
and gail people want to know when is the
congressman's funeral or memorial
service we're told that
that information won't be made public
until another civil rights icon
the late c.t vivian is laid to rest on
thursday simply out of respect
to him and his family
it's so hard to believe michelle that we
lost two of the greats just hours apart
on the same day but when you talk about
john lewis
they said he was a living example of the
power of healing and of love and he just
fought for justice
till his body just simply gave out
yes i'm told that it was simply a matter
of him
needing to go home and he was ready
yeah i heard that too thank you michelle
miller